discute pas dans cet établissement
laïque c'est certain dit prier dans
l'établissement les
commandes
mais c'est interdit c'est un
établissement laïc on n'a pas le droit
comment ça je filme moi je montre je
montre
si j'ai le droit de filmer par contre on
n'a pas le rose c'est un établissement
laïc
alors vous avez un cette polémique donc
on l'a vu sur le site de jean marc
morandini le syndicat étudiant de droite
uni publie une vidéo tournée
l'université de reims d'une jeune femme
musulmane faisant sa prière d'une salle
de cours gilles verdez fait pas du tout
choquée moi je suis choqué par le fait
qu'on l'a filmée je suis pas choqué
parce qu'elle faisait ça discrètement
sans prosélytisme sans enfant est
l'endroit où at war il y à un seul
exemple c'était à lille où une étudiante
avait fait ça dans les toilettes pour
prier une musulmane elle avait eu un
avertissement et en appel avait été
relaxé donc pour moi ce n'est pas
illégal et elle a le droit de le faire
si ça ne gêne personne d'autre voilà du
rallye alors déjà 1 je trouve que la
religion est beaucoup trop présente
encore est définitivement en france
aujourd'hui donc ça me pose vraiment un
problème toutes les religions un tous
les intégrismes ensuite moi ça me choque
parce que effectivement que l'ady gil
est laid out et malgré tout par part
parce que par ce syndicat donc je trouve
que c'est gênant ensuite je trouve ça
gênant parce que je trouve que c'est
humiliant de prier dans ces conditions
des reins un tableau un bureau sous un
escalier y en a qui font ça dans les
toilettes donc ça n'a aucun avenir ça
n'est pas possible c'est pas le lieu à
titre personnel enfin je suis d'accord
avec toi j parce que tout exercice de
culte est proscrit à l'université donc
finalement là elle est hors la loi donc
je pense qu'il faudrait soit être clair
soit l'interdire complètement dire on
n'a pas le droit de prix à l'université
curie et c'est comme ça soit on décide
de réfléchir comme dans les hôpitaux
comme dans les prisons alors 2 voilà
comme dans les aéroports des lieux
multiconfessionnelle où les gens peuvent
calmement dignement voilà prier d'accord
combat ce qui vous gêne dans cette vidéo
en fait tu étais tu dois de la création
à la loi mais elle ne les attendait
déjà le titre les titres d'articles
qu'on a pu lire il saura koller en
impression c'est une salle pleine c'est
une salle vide elle est discrète elle
est la seule elle ne dérange personne
n'a pas le droit de vous déranger dans
un lieu public chinois ce qui ne crient
pas d'y aller seul et s'est isolé c'est
pas le problème srdjan endroit en france
où ça doit être totalement laïque ce
sont les écoles et les universités les
hôpitaux pèlerins catholiques écoles
musulmanes face à l'école juive que tu
fais c'est que c'est fini on me dérange
c'est qu'on l'a filmé à son insu pour
l'humilie qu'on publie cette vidéo ça
c'est interdit on se parlait de
l'insulté je ne vois pas en quoi ça vous
dérange est rien
prix 17 pour dire c'est humiliant prier
comme ci comme ça c'est dans une
primaire excuse moi si tu veux si tu
veux y avait une superbe à neuilly si tu
veux une école catholique tu vas l'école
catholique située briller si tu veux des
communes ban ki-moon école juive tu y
vas là c'est cette université ces laïcs
ce n'est pas l'endroit pour c'est pas
autorisé points et 7 vers l'endroit où
la religion ne doit pas entrer ce sont
dans les écoles laïques les averses pays
laïc c'est qu'elles font que ça vous
choque plus j'ai l'impression que ces
gens font tout pour faire élire zemmour
c'est quand même fascinant non encore
une vidéo
polémique bah voilà oui de fait le plus
simple c'est de se mettre d'accord ont
pris soin chez soi à la maison soit dans
les lieux de culte est tout simplement
ça s'arrête là comme sa moi ya pas de
polémique et tout le monde est respectée
je pense que oui toi c'était comme pour
le comique toi la loi tu t'en fou ce
qu'on peut passer au delà les lois les
lois c'est toi qui les fait payer des
droits pour tous dans la vie pour
briller 2-0 à mathieu là on a
l'impression qu'elle est pris dans la
salle est pleine et
très bon guillaume le souci c'est s'est
elle fait ça sonne aujourd'hui comme ils
l'ont tous dit des camarades et c'est
pas un lieu pour prier c'est un lieu
pour aller du griffier un sérieux pour
iliad tu peux faire avant après tout il
n'ya pas de problème on va pas tant
vouloir si on n'en voudra pas de secret
là ce que tu me dis là aller seul c'est
à dire que si tu l'ès 1 2 3 et après
s'il y en a 30 dans la classe tu fais
comment vérité sur les gens parce
qu'elle est vous allez mais après une
prière catholique personne ne dirait
rien
eh bien ça le vrai malaise très bonne
question elles ont arrêté cinq étapes et
que tu aurais fait qu'autant et les miss
et ça prend la victoire ça qu'elle est
seule elle
parce qu'elle le fait 17 n'aurait c'est
simple dit quoi s'attendre à être
méchant mais nous plaît
5 là ce n'est plus pareil trois
individus heure légale d'exercer ses
ventes et ses saillies existe plein soit
finir que ce soit je vous rappelle que
les sénateurs dans la loi séparatisme
avait voulu mettre un article disant
qu'il est interdit de faire sa prière
dans les universités a été retoqué
donc ce n'est pas dans la loi le droit
titre a dit la bible de prier mais pour
gignac au journal asahi disposition la
loterie merci raymond gilles pourquoi
pourquoi attendre qu'elle soit 5 6 7 10
ou même des monsieur pourquoi attendre
pour compliquer le travail des gens qui
travaillent dans les universités pour
après faire des conflits pourquoi
attendre il ya une personne on désamorce
tout de suite on lui dit ici c'est pas
pour prier c'est pour étudier il ya des
lieux pour ça il ya chez toi garde ta
foi pour chez toi ne vient pas comme ça
te mettre par terre sortira un tapis et
prier selecon ici pourquoi attendre que
le phénomène gonfle ça sert à rien -
comme jeu comme je dis à chaque fois
quand j'ai grandi moi quand je faisais
il n'y avait pas ça avant jc n'y avait
pas à avancer ou doux c'est arrivé comme
ça que maintenant on fait des trucs
maintenant c'est dans la salle de classe
ou alors on met des comme à l'aéroport
comme vous avez dit on met des salles
exprès pour ça donc les écoles et on le
dit on après la laïcité c'est ce qu'ont
binaire 6